thankfully there was not a dry eye in
the room and I know that you guys were
particularly emotional as you accepted
to our award but your presence is so
needed in this energy industry and you
talked about that just talk about just
this day and it being your first feature
film and accepting this honor from your
on-screen mother I'm just soaking it in
moment by moment I don't really think
like how big this moment is in this
blessing it is it's gonna hit me until a
little later and then you being her
on-screen mom you said she feels like
your real-life daughter I mean talk
about that bond and presenting to her
she understands the power of the gift
she's been given just being in this room
feels like family so I think a lot of
people have an idea of what that means
you know just the energy in the room but
Kiki and I just immediately
just connected and she's allowed me to
mother off-screen as well you know she's
got a our mother they're very familiar
things that my mother possesses her
mother possesses so it just runs through
us hearing that from her how does that
even feel having a bonus mom I'm so very
thankful
but then this award in addition to
showing me who's already around me it
also also reminds me of who has come
before and all of the people who have
sacrificed so that I could be here days
away from my first Academy Award
ceremony last thing are you guys
breathing right now ahead of the Oscars
this is your first time attending it
your first time Oscar nominee just talk
to me about the feelings you guys have
right now the fact that we're here
representing James Baldwin's work we
could not ask for a better first
I mean what she just said I went to the
Oscars for the first time I'm
representing a James Bobin annexation
[Music]